what I'd like to do in this video is
make an informal argument for why the
formula for the area of a circle is PI R
squared and we're going to start just
with the most traditional definition of
the number pi and that's that and I'll
just do it here in a corner someplace
that pi is equal to the ratio of the
circumference and the diameter of the
circle or the ratio of the circumference
to the diameter of a circle or of course
we could write this as the ratio of the
circumference to instead of the diameter
I could write 2 times the radius or I
could multiply both sides times 2 times
the radius and we get our traditional
formula for the circumference for the
circumference of a circle but once again
this literally just comes straight out
of the definition for the number pi the
number pi is defined as the ratio
between the circumference in the
diameter so you just multiply both sides
of it times the diameter you get you get
the circumference is equal to PI times
the diameter now we have the
circumference formula right here once
again this comes out of the definition
of pi but from this I'd like to at least
get an intuitive feel for why the area
formula is given by PI R squared and to
think about that we're going to
approximate the area of polygons the
areas of polygons that are inscribed in
a circle so over here I have this was
this was a five-sided polygon right over
here and it's area is going to be equal
to so the area of this polygon it's
going to be 5 times the area of each of
those triangles in the area of each of
those triangles the height is a the base
is B so it's going to be base times
height or height times base times 1/2 so
this once again 5 times a be over 2 it's
not that good of an approximation this
is this would be the area of just the
inscribed polygon so we're definitely
under estimating the area of the entire
circle we're leaving out all of these
little these little chunks outside of
the polygon but still inside of the
circle but as we add more size to the
polygon we see that we're leaving out
less we see when we have now this is a 1
2 3 4 5 6
seven sided polygons where we're leaving
we're leaving a little bit less we're
under estimating still but we're under
estimating by less this area that we're
giving up isn't as large as this area
right over here so in this approximation
we have would I say seven triangles one
two three four five six seven triangles
and the area of each of those triangles
is once again a B over two now a and B
here are different than a and B over
here and notice what's happening as as
we increase as we increase the number of
triangles not only is it approximating
the area of the circle better but a is
getting longer and you can see as you
could imagine as as we increase many
many many more triangles a is going to
approach are now another thing to think
about is what is seven what is seven
times B approaching so we're saying that
a is approaching R as we add more of
these sides of the polygon as we add
more triangles and what is the number of
triangles times the base of the triangle
what is that approaching well this is
going to approach is going to approach
the perimeter of the pot or this is
going to be the perimeter of the polygon
so seven times B is that plus let me
actually let me draw this
it's that Plus that Plus that I think
you get the point Plus that Plus that
Plus that Plus that so once again seven
let me write this as seven times B that
is the perimeter of the polygon
perimeter perimeter of the polygon so
think about what's happening as we as we
have more and more sides of the polygon
are a are our height of each of our
triangles is going to approach our
radius is going to approach the radius
it's going to get long the height of
each of the triangle is gonna get longer
and longer it's going to approach the
radius as we have as we approach an
infinite number of triangles and then
the number of polygons we have or
the number of plugins the number of
sides we have times the basis that's
going to be the perimeter of the polygon
and as we add more and more sides as we
add more and more size the perimeter of
the polygon is going to approach is
going to approach is going to approach
the circumference of the circle I'll
write it out sir cumference
circumference and you see that even more
clearly right over here so once again
how many how many sides do I have here I
have one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten sides so this I can write
the perimeter of the polygon as ten
times B and then if I multiply that
times a over two if I multiply that
times just another color a over I'm just
write it up like this times a over two
I'm once again approximating the area of
the circle because a times B over two
that's the area of each of these
triangles and then I have ten of these
triangles but now let's think about this
more generally let's think about it if
if I were to have n if I would have an
n-sided polygon so I have an n-sided
polygon then I'd be approximating the
area as n times B and times B we see
this right over here when n is equal to
10 you have 10 times B so it's n times B
times a over 2 times a over 2 and it's
right why this isn't something
mysterious the base times the height
divided by 2 this is the this right over
here that's the area of each triangle
and then I'm going to have n of these
triangles so this is our approximation
for the area so let me write this the
area is going to be approximately that
right over there it's going to be n the
number of triangles I have times the
area of each triangle now what's going
to happen as n approaches infinity is
have it as I approach having an infinite
sided
on as I have an infinite number of
triangles so let's just think this
through a little bit because this is
where it gets interesting and this is
the informal argument to do this to do
this better I'd have to I'd have to dig
out a little bit of calculus but this
gives you the essence so let's just
think about what happens as n approaches
infinity so as n approaches infinity
we've already said as we have more and
more sides we have more and more
triangle eight more and more triangles a
approaches are so let's write that down
so a is going to approach R the height
of the triangles is going to approach
the radius and what else is going to
happen well n times B the perimeter of
the polygon the perimeter of the polygon
is going to approach the circumference
so a is going to approach R and n times
B is going to approach the circumference
is going to approach the circumference
or another way of thinking about if it's
approaching the circumference we could
say that n times B is going to approach
2 pi times the radius because that's
what the circumference is going to be
equal to so if a is approaching the
radius and n B is approaching 2 pi R
well then what is the entire what is the
area of what is the area of our polygon
or what is the area of our of ours what
is the area of our polygon going to or
the area of our circle going to be well
it is going to it is going to approach
it is going or I should say the area of
our polygon is going to approach and B
is going to approach 2 PI R and B is
going to approach 2 PI R so instead of n
V I'm writing 2 pi are there a is going
to approach our a is going to approach R
and then I'm dividing it and then I am
dividing it by 2 so as n approaches
infinity is we have an infinite number
of sides of our polygon an infinite
number of triangles the area of our
polygon will approach this which is
equal to what well you have two divided
by two and then PI R times R is equal to
PI R squared
so as our as we as we approach having an
infinite number of triangles and
infinite I want to keep that there an
infinite number of sides we see that we
approach the area of the circle and as
we approach the area of the circle we
are approaching PI R squared so
hopefully this gives you an intuitive
sense why this right over here is the
formula for the area of a circle you
could think about it is the area of an
infinite site an infinite sided polygon
that is inscribed in the circle which
will be equal to the area of the circle